tengo esto que no me sirve a reciclar
sus desechos electrónicos como ella cada
ecuatoriano acumula un promedio de 5,3
kilogramos anuales en un país sin
cultura de reciclado no sabemos dónde
desecharnos Porque si bien es cierto
tirarlos a la basura nos perjudica al
medio ambiente pues no y más bien
tenemos que colaborar hoy en día para un
mejor mundo oportunidad que motiva
Gustavo Marriott un analista de sistemas
convertido en gestor ambiental quien
intenta concienciar a los Ecuatorianos
con la instalación de contenedores
elaborados de desechos plásticos y
residuos electrónicos para deshacerse
los aparatos tecnológicos en desuso
todo comienza aquí con 35 toneladas de
residuos tecnológicos casi el 100% puede
ser aprovechada o reinsertada en el
mercado el 95% de lo que nosotros
procesamos es recuperable Es decir desde
el plástico el cobre el aluminio la
chatarra
despiertados localmente y lo que se
exporta básicamente son las tarjetas
electrónicas a refinerías donde lo que
hacen es fundir el material y recuperar
oro paladio plata en este pequeño centro
de recuperación Wander Nieves técnico
informático fomenta un mercado circular
emergente Ecuador está promoviendo una
normativa que obligue a productores y
empresarios a recuperar los desechos
electrónicos que produce la cadena
productiva para que puedan seguir dando
sus funciones y así apoyando aquellas
personas cuyos recursos son muy bajos
dando los equipos a buen precio
impresoras se fomenta la economía
circular reduciendo la huella de carbono
de productos
de vuelta este centro de recolección que
dividen desarman y clasifican la basura
tecnológica
destruye y compactan por en práctica el
eco valor y la responsabilidad extendida
de productos nuevos términos a los que
Gustavo acostumbra a los Ecuatorianos
esto significan 90.000 toneladas al año
de esto solamente entre el 3 y el 5% de
reciclado correctamente una minería
urbana que aspira a liberar de su basura
tecnológica en menos de 10 años al
Ecuador